bang bang the country of malaysia is now
proposing that they should adopt bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies as legal tender as
we have been discussing every single
country is going to do this but to see
the malaysian government going ahead and
proposing the adoption of crypto assets
as legal tender is a big big deal we
have a quote here from the deputy
minister of communications what he
states is we hope the government can try
to legalize this matter so that we can
expand the participation of young people
and cryptocurrencies and help them in
terms of energy consumption and so on
now of course having the malaysian
government adopt bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies is a really big deal
but this is a 180 degree different
position than what they were doing just
last year many of you may remember this
viral video of them literally
steamrolling bitcoin mining machines
look at how crazy this was just an epic
image of exactly how the government felt
about bitcoin and cryptocurrencies now
the malaysian government is obviously
not the only country in the world that
is adopting these technologies we know
that the el salvador government they've
gone ahead and they've made bitcoin
legal tender they've plugged their
entire country into the bitcoin network
from atm networks to individual mobile
apps to literally paying their citizens
30 worth of bitcoin on top of that
lugano switzerland has started the
process to make bitcoin legal tender as
well and ultimately that's where we're
headed every single country in the world
is going to realize that bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are the future they are
going to have to adopt these
technologies their young people are
already using them and over time they
realize bitcoin is good for business
bitcoin is good for the politicians
bitcoin is good for the people and
eventually they will see that bitcoin is
good for the corporations as well
bitcoin is the future and these
countries are realizing it bitcoin will
become legal tender in every country
that wants to remain competitive on the
global landscape hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time